[Music]
while Bettinger CEO Charles Schwab
welcome to the industrialist alumna into
Stanford I appreciate it thanks so much
Rob it's a pleasure to be here
so when the company started the company
started by disrupting the equities
market and yet now you have three point
three trillion dollars under management
at the company so you've gone from this
disruptive you know upstart to what has
become a very very important player in
the financial services space but yet the
company still thinks of itself as a
disruptor can you tell us a little bit
about that well I think our view is that
disruption doesn't have anything to do
with how large you are or how long
you've been into in existence disruption
is really a state of mind it revolves
around two things one is your focus on
your customers and not just their needs
today but also the anticipation of what
their needs will be and then the second
oddly enough we think it's just courage
it's the willingness to recognize that
in order to grow in order to evolve in
the business world we live in today you
have to be willing to say we do this for
customers today we've done this for a
long time but it's not the right thing
anymore we're going to have to change
and actually disrupt ourselves so when
you have to change something one of the
important things we've talked about in
the past is Trust in fact I think when
we met last time you must have used the
word trust a hundred times how do you
try new things and yet still maintain
that trust with your customers and your
clients well our business is so much
different than other businesses because
it's about people's money and it's about
what we call OPM or other people's money
and the way people deal with finances is
much more emotional than maybe buying a
new suit or even buying a new car and
the other thing you have to bear in mind
when you're dealing with money is that
the markets don't just go up they go
down too and so unlike say a traditional
retail model or a web-based model we're
going to have our clients disappointed
maybe 40 percent of the time when the
markets move down and so Trust has to be
at the core of the services we provide
so that they believe and stay invested
and help themself in the long run by
being in the market even though their
ups and downs so if you have you know a
great number of clients a lot of capital
under man
judgment Trust is important and now we
have new technologies data and
information you know a lot about your
customers how do you take data and use
it in your business in a way that helps
build trust and what are the risks that
you've seen where it hasn't gone maybe
as you anticipated sure well we do have
a lot of data a lot of information on
our clients what we want to do with that
information is find better ways to serve
them to serve their needs what we don't
want to do is use that data in a manner
that undermines the trust that we just
finished speaking about and and that can
be complicated because oftentimes we can
know things about our clients that maybe
others don't know if they for example go
to our website to the life event section
and click on divorce we might know
something before their spouse does and
so what we do with that information to
ensure that it's both held
confidentially but also used to serve
them not sell is very very important in
the building of trust how do you think
about the younger generation the newer
Schwab clients who want to interact with
companies in different way the
importance of mobile less time they want
to spend on the phone how do you use
tools to help them as they get into
saving and investing and how do you have
to treat those customers differently
perhaps and then say my generation well
what's really interesting is that the
use of mobile platforms digital is not
age centric we actually have customers
in all age ranges up into the 90s who
are on their mobile devices on the web
interacting with us in a more digital
manner what we want to try to do is use
technology to better serve our clients
in the areas where they don't want to
necessarily speak to someone they can
process something faster by just doing
it in a digital or an online manner but
we also want to make sure that there's
not a trade off so that our clients can
always speak to us about things that are
important to have a live person having a
conversation with so in the early days
of Schwab company was a technological
innovator and built its own back-end for
trades and everything else and now in
today's world managing is as large of an
organization as you are how do you
decide what technologies that Schwab
wants to invest in and keep in-house and
where do you want to look to partner
with other outside or
and what are the things that might
impact your companies that might not
impact other large companies and
partnerships yes well the challenge with
technology is it's increasingly
difficult with you to create sustainable
differentiation on technology what one
organization can build other
organizations can build quite similarly
and so we leverage technology partners
in areas that we consider more
commoditized and the type of work we do
in-house is things that we think are
unique to us in creating unique
capabilities one of the other dilemmas
in an industry like ours which has such
stringent oversight from federal
regulation standpoint is anyone we
partner with really has to have the same
level of regulatory oversight that we do
and that rules out a lot of technology
companies for us to try to do business
together with so as you look forward the
next five to ten years and you think
about all the changes that you've seen
in the business you now I've been with a
company over 20 years since they
acquired your first company what do you
think about over the next five to ten
years what are the top two or three
things that are keeping you up at night
well the thing that's happening in our
industry is not different than what's
happening across business everywhere and
that is this concept of no trade offs
the consumer can expect and will
actually be able to get the lowest price
the best service and world-class advice
that's not what has historically been
the way the world operated in the
investment services arena that you made
a trade office to orderly I can have low
cost but I may not get the best service
or I can have great advice but boy am I
going to pay a premium to get it all
those walls are breaking down and the
consumer is going to be able to get
everything that they might desire
without trade-offs frankly we think they
get that today at Schwab and that's
partly why we've been acquiring market
share as rapidly as we have so one final
question why a Schwab able to do that
when other companies can't be at the
old-line wire houses or the new upstarts
that are coming up in the FinTech space
how are you and your organization able
to be successful where others haven't
been well I think there's a lot of
companies that have successful models
that work for them but ours is a bit
unique we combine tremendous scale with
well over three trillion dollars in
Incline assets tremendous efficiency
operating
at a fraction of the cost of any of our
publicly traded competitors we don't
have legacy infrastructure for example
high paid salespeople things of that
nature and of course we've always been
as you mentioned from the beginning
technology driven and so we're in this
constant effort to figure out ways to
use technology to be more efficient in
hamp service but also lower our costs
and then the last thing we're always
willing to share it back with our
clients last year alone we voluntarily
reduced our pricing to clients to the
tune of about 5% of our overall revenue
and yet still grew revenue in the
mid-teens
so really you are trying to be in that
one quadrant where you're the low cost
leader and the high service provider I
think that's the only way organizations
win going forward in our business
society you're going to have to be the
no trade-offs companies to really be the
big winners well thank you so much for
coming to Stanford and thank you for
coming to our class it's an honor to be
here thanks so much pleasure to have you
[Music]